oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so if you live in Maine
specifically near the Canadian border oh
man these scientists saw a meteor fly
through the sky they don't know where it
ended up but if you can find it and you
can bring it to the museum They're Gonna
Give You 25k it's probably worth 25 mil
I know I thought they already have 25
minutes I've seen Joe Dirt I'm keeping
that [__] I think if I found it I would
go over there like grab a like a bucket
or something like start mining to see if
there's anything interesting in there
like minerals and stuff and then just
take it for myself
oh yeah you know I found it because what
if there's something that's in the meter
that's like worth something you know
like some sort of rare metal yeah what
if you touched it and then like a week
later you start getting an eye over here
oh vibranium you got vibranium that's
true our meteors uh you start turning
into like thing or what do you call
Venom thing Venom
that's how you know I don't know nothing
about [__] superheroes
he's that Chinese guy Fang
leafing
dude yeah so you don't even have to
bring in the whole thing they just want
one kilogram at least one oh okay don't
like just give us a link because they
also don't know how much of it might be
left but if you got at least a kilogram
of it you can bring that imma bring it
four kilograms to get 100 G's wouldn't
they know where it is though well they
know generally where it might be but
because they're not allowed to just go
on anyone's property looking for a
meteorite they're asking the public like
check your own places because maybe it
could have hit like a national forest
too like in the middle of nowhere right
and like I think this kind of area like
there's lots of land I think it's like a
10 15 mile radius where they know that
it's located but again like some people
own like that whole area right here and
they can't step on what do you learn
from them from media you know from a
meteor like what what uh space data I
don't know space maybe they're looking
for Superman nerd [__] when it comes to
[__] like this I don't know [__] but one
thing I do know is uh I think it's very
interesting to scientists to find things
that aren't on the element table
um that we already know about like iron
or phosphorus or whatever like vibranium
dude yeah so for them if they can test
what is vibranium it's only wakanda had
it for a minute it's not real dude you
had me going I was like what
tell me more nowadays yeah there's other
people that got it yeah
I had when I was a kid we thought that I
was gonna develop like a an element I
was gonna create that was your goal as a
child yeah no no my head I was just
thinking like a prophecy what if I like
find a cure for all this like you know
all these diseases I'm like what if I
find it
it's under your shoe what if I figure it
out no dude the next thing I'm about to
say is even more stupid so I would get
all the [__] chemicals that were
under the bathroom and I'll put it in
the pot and I will just start [__]
and just take a big whiff
like that 409
I put it in a pot it just [__] lift
it up yeah it was dangerous yeah my dad
got mad at me one time he's telling me
like he went in the [__] door because
you know no [__] door locks in a
Mexican [__] house you know it's
always like weird you open it so I'm
like
he thought he acted like I was doing
drugs what the hell what are you doing
and I'm trying to explain to him my
innocent brain and just like oh I'm
developing you know curing cancer
and you're like [__] things up you're
barging and hearing it I mean ruining my
research yeah I do it in the nude but
still dude this is how I do it and my
dad's like
you're gonna kill yourself with the
chemical you're breathing it in that
band that's gonna come up and my mom
what happened it's like
he's already stupid in my mind
he's already I'm actually I actually
think I'm pretty smart
he's already stupid he's making himself
I don't think stupider is a word but
whatever
you're an idiot you're sick come back
yeah
sit come back I remember we had to get
PSAs in elementary school not to mix
Clorox and Ajax so that fume actually is
like oh like put you out right put you
out or something yeah all that was in
there dude
those two I think specific Ally you put
it together so how did
how did you know recipe dude
did you didn't I feel like a kid like
you would have tried it no I think for
me like I had a good danger radar too so
I was like okay people are passing out
no I probably shouldn't do that
yeah I was hearing [__] about kids
putting Forks in the socket and I was
like what idiot does that I heard that
as a kid too watch your mouth dude were
you trying to get your hair to go like
Maddie I don't even know this is a
stories my parents told me it was like
you know those Chinese ear diggers yeah
I would grab them and I would just put
them in the socket oh my God you know
what that is oh yeah no dude but they're
wood aren't they no it's metal it's like
you literally have an ear digger
and just like you clean out your ears
with it no crazy right what did yours
look like just like a typical like gold
one but like did it have the Swirl at
the end or was it just the scoop it's
it's just one little scoop long and then
one little scoop yeah I think so I don't
remember what happened because my brain
is damaged so you know what I figured
out one time we're uh we were playing
with uh we weren't playing with dry ice
but we had dry ice and that was uh and
uh
chemistry or whatever in high school and
I remember she was like don't like don't
put it in in a cap and that's what she
was saying it's like don't put in don't
close the lid and I was like all right
but then I'll say why not
I didn't know that so I didn't put water
and then I just [__] threw it in
there and it Bubbles and it just like I
just threw it in the [__] closed it
it was from like one of those Dasani
Waters so it's like thick oh yeah so
it's just [__] a thick bottle and
that thing just I knew it was starting
to get around I'm like what the [__] my
dumb ass was like this close to it it
was just like what though
where all these little ridges started
getting like really like softened up so
it just looked like a huge [__] and I'm
like oh it looks funny dude it looks
like I'm looking at my friend dude what
the [__] is that and we're just looking
at it two idiots and then the little lit
the label just start it cracked up and
I'm like huh and then
Boom the biggest one I'm talking about
boom where my
um
this thing was all formed and all that
[__] [__] and the teacher flipped the
[__] out she's like
three classrooms came out they're all
like asking they're okay what's going on
and I'm just like oh
but dude then here's the worst part is
that I found out in my local [__]
bonds they sell dry ice and they also
sell to Sunny
so this guy went
I'm like why would I buy firecrackers
when I could just dig this dude and I
didn't know it was illegal to do that oh
I didn't even know that they sold dry
ice at Vons they sell dry ice I don't
know why but they're yeah they're saying
but it's illegal to do it I don't know
what the cop came and talked to us
afterwards like I was like this is
illegal to put it together yeah well
that's like you're technically making a
bomb is what he said and it was like all
right [__] that is America
but all right dude it's actually a
flashbang sir yeah
concussion grenade yeah isn't that
making it explosive because it's
exploding yeah you're technically making
like a bucket we did put ice box under
it and then just [__] watch it yeah
it's not like you put nails in the
bottle or anything like with a two liter
area
[__] dude used to do that with the two
liter sodas and then throw them and then
they explode and they turn a rocket yeah
you see my dad would get mad at that we
tried that once but he was like you're
wasting 40 or you know how much that
costs I'm like two dollars
but all right broke [__]
well yeah dude I used to make sure I was
a bomb maker I guess yeah
I was a bomb stealer FBI's watching you
since then dude like this guy he's got
it in him whenever he [__] bites the
sun he does some weird [__] dude yeah I
used to make like old school slingshots
too like a Mexican slingshots what's a
Mexican thing
Mexican you need a Dasani bottle again
can you break it
and then
so now you have oh yeah and then you
have like a balloon you cut the end of
the balloon right there and then you tie
it at the other end really tight now you
put like rocks in there and just wow
I did that so fast
and they just hit [__] in the
back of the head in class
oh you know what I think I could shoot
this let me see give me a copy
you're reminding me of childhood [__]
yeah dude what was the childhood [__]
invention give me a cat there's rubber
bands oh dude I've done that a bunch of
times dude I know what you're doing oh
yeah yeah well you twisting no no you
don't know you don't know yeah don't act
like you grew up in society
oh yeah you have to do a little twist
yeah no don't do it over here
dude there's water in there yeah and
then oh it's just oh
[Laughter]
these kids these days dude I don't know
if these are 3D printers
hahaha
[Music]
foreign